una de las siete maravillas del mundo
está en alerta la ministra de cultura de
Perú Betsy Chávez advirtió que el
desgaste de Machu Picchu debería
preocupar no solo los peruanos sino a
toda la humanidad en efecto hizo un
llamado a la conciencia lo que queremos
pedirles más bien A toda la ciudadanía a
todos nuestros hermanos turistas
nacionales y extranjeros es que
protejamos el patrimonio cultural esta
semana se han producido protestas en
Aguas calientes ciudad desde la cual se
accede a la ciudad de la inca así como
debate sobre el aforo del lugar puesto
que la UNESCO recomienda una cifra de
visitantes diarios que no es compartida
por trabajadores de la zona en la región
en la que se encuentra el complejo
arqueológico existe un aforo autorizado
de 4044 personas sin embargo en julio
pasado la unidad de gestión aprobó el
incremento de la cabida en Machu Picchu
en mil espacios esto para permitir la
reactivación de sus actividades
duramente golpeadas desde el inicio de
la pandemia de Kobe 19 pero el aumento
en la demanda amenaza su preservación y
ponen evidencia la necesidad de un
turismo sostenible y tenemos que
trabajar el tema de manera transversal
por un lado la protección del patrimonio
porque sin patrimonio no hay turismo
pero es importante también inyectar
estas palabras de turismo responsable el
lunes 15 de agosto la ministra se reunió
con el gobernador Regional de cusco el
alcalde de Machu Picchu y con
representantes de los gremios que se
encargan del sector turístico en esta
región para impulsar nuevos acuerdos en
pro de salvaguardar el patrimonio
peruano